beavis and butthead wasn't meant for
kids but they probably watched it anyway
because it was hilarious
but now that the children of the 90s
have grown into adults they should watch
the show again to catch everything they
missed the first time around you can
tell that beavis and butt-head are
metalheads because when a metal video
comes on to the TV they shout things
like this rules while they head bang and
play air guitar and of course Beavis is
always wearing a Metallica t-shirt while
butt-head rocks one for ac/dc as you're
probably aware these are both famous
metal bands that even casual music fans
are familiar with but to an older viewer
it's clear that creator Mike judge
didn't just pick those two bands
randomly early on in the show Beavis is
the more serious and demented of the two
generally wanting to cause destruction
it makes sense that he wears a Metallica
shirt as that band takes itself very
seriously and is dedicated to a non-stop
sonic assault
Butthead however just wants to have a
good time much like the Australian band
behind party hits like you shook me all
night long and TNT and then there
Stewart the nerd who emulates beavis and
butt-head and desperately wants to hang
out with them he just can't get it right
though he wears a shirt in support of
winger a cheesy hair metal band nowhere
near as legit as Metallica and ac/dc in
other words winger is lame and so is
Stewart for a sizable chunk of the 90s
teenagers across the land imitated
beavis and butt-head 'he's ridiculous
laughs and catchphrases there probably
wasn't ever a single junior high lunch
period without some kid pulling his
shirt over his head proclaiming himself
the great cornholio and yelling i need
TP for my bunghole but looking back on
the show with the wisdom and education
afforded by adulthood it's clear now
that beavis and butt-head spurn Acula
had no basis in reality 90s kids
delighted and calling each other bone
hole as if it was a dirty word but in
fact it isn't or at least it didn't used
to be while beavis and butt-head may
have made bunghole synonymous with
another kind of hole it turns out that
it's actually just the name for an
opening in a barrel one of the most
frequent targets of beavis and butt-head
shenanigans was their neighbor tom
anderson tom is a patriotic conservative
beer drinking guy he likes to work with
tools and mow his lawn
he gets easily upset and he
beaks and short sentences in a
high-pitched Texas drawl does that sound
familiar it should because Tom Anderson
shares virtually the same appearance and
speech patterns of a later more famous
cartoon character
Hank Hill on king of the hill that show
like beavis and butt-head was created by
Mike judge who also voiced both Tom and
Hank Hank like Tom is a patriotic
conservative beer-drinking lawn and tool
obsessed guy even Tom's wife Marcy looks
quite a bit like Hanks wife Peggy the
only difference is that while the hills
are middle-aged the Andersons are well
into their golden years beavis and
butthead 'he's whole deal is that
they're stupid
they enjoy stupid things they do stupid
things they're barely functional at
school and in society and they never
stop laughing they're stupid laughs but
almost everybody can find their niche in
this great big world even those who are
as stupid and seemingly useless as
beavis and butt-head for them their
skill is music criticism honed by
countless hours of watching music videos
even if they can't get the names of the
musicians right they know what they like
and what they don't their attitude
towards music could easily be applied
towards all of life Butthead once stated
I like stuff that's cool and I don't
like stuff that sucks
that may sound like a logic loop but
maybe it's really just a prompt for a
challenging philosophical conundrum do
we like something because it's cool or
is it cool because we like it is
inherent quality non-existent or at
least irrelevant because it's impossible
to view things objectively independent
of our own perceptions and tastes Beavis
and Butthead really makes you think most
TV shows are about something insofar as
they have a premise or a point the
office for example Minds humor out of
the work place a near universal
experience for most adults Modern Family
meanwhile focuses on the home life of a
group of relatives but only beavis and
butt-head was audacious and
transgressive enough to be about another
aspect of the day that eats up a lot of
time the act of watching TV to get more
specific beavis and butthead was about
two guys that sat around on a couch
channel surfing and looking for stuff
that was cool
that a TV show about watching TV could
exist and even thrive is basically some
kind of postmodern commentary on the
degradation of culture and human
interaction at the same time all those
segments of beavis and butt-head
watching
TV are a very subtle form of advertising
in the original series all they viewed
were music videos which is essentially a
constant directive to viewers to stay
tuned to MTV Wow my life was cool check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]